it looks like a capital under siege
fences topped with razor wire have been
erected around the nation's seat of
government
ever increasing numbers of soldiers are
being deployed
security officials saying that some 20
000
will be sent by the inauguration next
wednesday
that's greater than any current
deployment anywhere in the world
even the supreme court is being locked
down
as well as other signature landmarks
once thronged with tourists
vice president mike pence met with
senior security officials
to be briefed on the preparations the
american people
deserve a safe
inauguration on january 20th
and i encourage you to convey to all of
the members of your teams
to continue to lean forward to ensure
that we achieve
just that but he heard a bleak
assessment
from the director of the fbi uh we're
concerned about the potential for
violence
at multiple protests and rallies planned
here in dc and at state capitol
buildings around the country
in the days to come that could bring
armed individuals within close proximity
to government buildings and officials
and direct threats from right-wing
extremists have been growing
in the wake of the impeachment vote
against president trump on wednesday
i was taped to my office store just a
few minutes ago
the republicans who voted for
impeachment a particular focus
colleagues who are now traveling with
armed escorts
out of the fear for their safety many of
us are altering our routines
working to get body armor as yet another
ominous evening fell
the vice president thanked some of the
national guard that had been deployed to
the nation's capital
on a scale not seen since the civil war
mike hanna al-jazeera washington